again maybe a romanticized philosophical
question but when you look up at the
stars knowing that you know there's at
least a hundred billion of them in the
Milky Way galaxy right so we're really a
small speck in this giant thing that's
the visible universe how does that make
you feel about our efforts here
I love the perspective I love that
perspective I always opened my public
talks with a big Hubble Space Telescope
image looking out until you'd mentioned
just now the solar system the Milky Way
because I really I think it's really
important to know that we're just a
small pill blue dot we're really
fortunate we're on the best planet by
far life is fantastic we know of you're
confident this is the best planet planet
that we know of I mean I searched my
research is you know mission worlds and
when will we find life I think actually
in probably the next decade we find
probably past life probably the evidence
of past life on Mars let's say you think
there was pretty like once life on Mars
or do you think there's currently I'm
more comfortable saying about 3.5
billion years ago feel pretty confident
there was life on Mars just because then
it had an electromagnetic shield it had
an atmosphere has wonderful gravity
level three 3sg is fantastic you know
you're all super human we can all slam
dunk a basketball I mean it's gonna be
fun to play sports on Mars but so I
think we'll find past that no fossilize
probably the evidence of past life on
Mars currently that's again we need the
next decade but the evidence is mounting
for sure we do have the organics we're
finding organics we have water seasonal
water on Mars we used to just know about
the ice caps you know north and south
pole now we have seasonal water we do
have the building blocks for life on
Mars we really need to dig down into the
soil because everything on the top
surface is radiated but once we find
down will we see any any life form so we
see any bugs
I live it open as a possibility but I
feel pretty certain that past life or
you know fossilized life forms will find
and then we have to get to all these
ocean worlds these these beautiful moons
of other other planets since we know
they have water and we're looking for
since simple search for life or follow
the water
you know carbon-based life that's the
only life we know there could be other
life forms
we don't know about but it's hard to
search for them because we don't know so
in our search for life in the solar
system it's definitely you know search
you know let's follow the water and look
for the building blocks of life do you
think in the next decade we might see
hints of past life or even currently I
think so I'm pretty active you humans
have to be involved or can this be
robots and Rovers and probably teams I
mean we've been at it on Mars in
particularly 50 years we've been
exploring Mars for 50 years great day
that right our images of Mars today are
phenomenal now we know how Mars lost its
atmosphere you know we're starting to
know because of the lack of the
electromagnetic shield we know about the
water on Mars so we've been studying 50
years with our robots we still haven't
found it so I think once we have a human
mission there we just accelerate things
it's always humans and our Rovers and
robots together but we just have to
think that 50 years we've been looking
at Mars Mars and taking images and doing
the best science that we can people need
to realise Mars this really far away
it's really hard to get to you know this
is extreme extreme exploration we've
mentioned Magellan first or all of the
wonderful explorers and sailors of the
past which kind of are lots of my
inspiration for exploration Mars is a
different ballgame I mean eight months
to get there year-and-a-half to get home
I mean it's really extreme environment
in all kinds of ways but the kind of
organisms we might be able to see hints
of on Mars are kind of micro organisms
perhaps I remember that humans were kind
of you know we're hosts right we're
hosts all of our bacteria and viruses
right do you think it's a big leap from
the viruses in the bacteria to us humans
put another way do you think on all
those moons beautiful wet moons that you
mentioned you think there's intelligent
life out there I hope so I mean that's
that's the hope but you know we don't
have the scientific evidence for that
now I think all the evidence we have in
terms of life existing is much more
compelling again because we have the
building blocks of life now when that
life turns into intelligence that's a
big unknown if we ever meet do you think
we would be able to find a common
language I hope so
we haven't met yet it's just so far I
mean do physics just play a role here
look at all these exoplanets 6000
exoplanets I mean
even the couple dozen earth-like planets
or exoplanets that really look like
habitable planets these are very
earth-like they look like they have all
the building blocks I can't wait to get
there the only thing is they're 10 to
100 light years away so scientifically
we know they're there we know that
they're habitable they have you know
everything going from right like you
know the Goldilocks zone not too hot not
too cold just perfect for how to have
the ability for life but now the reality
is if they're ten at the best to a
hundred to thousands of light-years away
so what's out there but I just can't
think that we're not the only ones so
absolutely life life in the universe
probably intelligent life as well
you